[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 17th episode of dirty
chess tricks
in today's lecture we are going to see a
wonderful
high profile queen trap in the nimsovich
scandinavian variation from the white
perspective
after e4 there are two ways actually
black can reach to the critical position
let's say in this game
black plays knight to c6 first
and after our knight to f3 apart from e5
the only other break black is having
here is
d5 and after e captures d5
and queen captures d5 i recommend
this straightforward move knight to c3
now obviously enough black really do not
want to go back to the d square
as not only white will get space in the
center
with d4 but black has this backwards c
pawn which can no longer challenge the
white center
so accordingly queen to a5 is by far
the most popular choice and after that
white initiative continue with bishop to
b5
so if allowed then we really chop off on
c6
and give black some horrible pawn
structure
so black shouldn't allow it and
accordingly
bishop to d7 is the logical choice
here white has tried various responses
such as castle as well as d4
but recent theory suggests that
white should start with this very tricky
move
a3 which sets up a cunning platform
for our upcoming tricks
well black has few options but amongst
them
if he continue with castle on side
then i think after white castle white
can quickly launch an
attack via the moon b4 and this
positions
are always strong for the wide
and same goes to other move namely
knight to f6
as after rook to b1 and b4 once again
white get tremendous space on the queen
side
so accordingly if you check the online
database
a6 has been highestly played here
and it looks very logical black
wants to release the tension before he
castle
on the queen side well guess what
yup this is exactly where black
fallen into of a tricky dietary
did you find the star move in this
position
absolutely right before
and suddenly black to his horror
find out that the game has been finished
just within the opening stage
here black has two responses
one trap the queen and the second one
where black indeed managed to escape
but at the end still get the losing
position
by far the most popular choice here is
knight captures b4
which again looks like neutralize all
white threat
as if white take the bishop then after
king catches d7
black is all set to do the artificial
castle
and yes indeed at first sight it looks
like
white's all threats are gone except
one more did you spot it
congratulations if you find this
wonderful resource
boom
what a move well clearly
black is a piece down so if you don't
take over rook
then he get a completely losing position
[Music]
so let's see what is the big idea after
queen captures even
[Music]
and i think this theme crop up again and
again
in many different openings after white's
next reply
more or less black can pack his back and
go home
as knight to d4
and suddenly after knight to b3
black queen has been trapped down and
funny enough even though black can see
it coming
he cannot do anything about it
fortunately one of my game recently
reached to this position and my opponent
who has more than 2100 rating
continued with a5 and after
knight to b3 he decided
to capture my knight on c3 which is in
fact even a bad version as after
simple pawn recapture comes with a check
and after king to see it and the moon
knight captures a5
if you count the material just within
the 13th moon
white get a queen against the rook
and a misplaced king which is obvious
enough
close to a completely winning advantage
the second move i want to consider is
queen to b6
and against this white response is very
obvious
knight to d5 and black has to be very
careful
as if he foolishly take over bishop
then after this old trick knight
captured c7
white get family 4 and in fact
after this black position is completely
collapsing so no
that's not possible that means black
queen has the only square
namely a7
but after that okay we are not getting
queen
but we get this forcing sequence
knight capture c7 jack king to d8
now white shouldn't take the rook in the
corner as he will lose
two pieces for a rook so here
my advice is you should first capture on
c6
which forces black hand as he cannot
take on c6
as his own rook hangs so accordingly
king capture c7 is the best reply
but after bishop captures d7 king
captures d7
and the moon castle once again
if you count the material this time
around
white is just upon up but
look at the pathetic position of black
king and
as i have highlighted by the arrows once
the white
complete his beast development with the
space in the center
due to the open king black is really
going to struggle
for the rest of the game
not so surprisingly at this position
chess engine gives plus three
yup you heard it right plus three
advantage to wide
which with accurate play close to
a completely winning one
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile trick in the knight c6
scandinavian variation
remember at this point continue with
a3 and once the black respond with
a6 after our trademark move b4
black has to decide whether he wants to
sacrifice a queen
or leads to a position where
white can get all the fun where black
king
is stuck in the center
thank you for watching this video feel
free to like subscribe
and comment and i will meet you in my
next episode
very soon bye and take care